I wish you were little when I sleep when
I'm not cold
[Music]
no it's not unreasonable at all excuse
me Oh take it to boss ladies on a
warpath this morning every morning for
you always mean I got big and I got rich
so now we're gonna check me boo I wish
you were
everyone else you're a child so you have
to start acting like it
get back to work whose child is this
walking around here in a tiny pink
pantsuit
what's Child Protective Services
enrolled this child in school or
somebody is going to jail that's
somebody do you mean daughter's adorable
I could tell that you are a special
young lady effect get me I feel like I'd
get you to so you feeling what I'm
feeling no I'm not feeling that at all
don't don't look at me like that just
look look look at the other way look
through it look the look up there you
have a chance anyone would kill for
maybe you have to do something
differently at this age Botox
figure the boss of me say one more thing
I dare you you're too fat for that skirt
okay see I've been looking at you like a
little girl but you a grown-ass woman we
have a BMW situation black mama whooping
yes mommy my mama
you